oula le ciel se couvre et pourquoi les
nuages passe-t-il du blanc au gris le
soleil émet de la lumière blanche
il s'agit en fait d'une combinaison de
plusieurs ondes électromagnétiques qui
correspondent aux couleurs de l'arc en
ciel
il y a aussi les ondes
électromagnétiques auxquels nos yeux ne
sont pas sensibles en théorie la lumière
se déplace en ligne droite quand elles
pénètrent dans l'atmosphère terrestre
elles rencontrent des obstacles et les
molécules qui composent l'air et quand
il ya des nuages comme aujourd'hui la
vapeur d'eau les gouttelettes et les
cristaux de glace qui forment ces
nébulosité ces obstacles absorbe et
dévie la lumière en la diffusant dans
toutes les directions
voilà pourquoi les nuages nous
apparaissent blanc comme la lumière
émise par le soleil
enfin tant que le nuage n'est pas trop
épais les cumulonimbus ces nuages qui se
forme quand il ya de l'orage peuvent
s'étirer sur une quinzaine de kilomètres
de hauteur
dans ces conditions la lumière est
quasiment entièrement absorbée par la
tête du nuage la base n'est plus
éclairée elle ne diffuse plus ou très
peu de lumière
le nuage est gris parfois presque noir
ou là j'ai la tête dans les nuages
un peu comme dans une capsule de descons
fini si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celle des jours précédents il vous
suffit de cliquer sur la gauche j'en
réalise une nouvelle chaque jour et pour
être sûr de ne louper aucune et bien
abonnez vous et activer la petite cloche
à demain et n'oubliez pas nous sommes
confinés
mais on reste en lien